So we said we were going to
have controls in place,
that we're going to have
people responsible,
we're going to have policy to inform
people of our do's and don'ts and
things like that, but that's not
going to reduce our risk to zero.
There's still the possibility,
because there are non-vulnerabilities,
where people became victims
of a phishing attack,
we hear about those on a regular basis.
So the risk is not going to go down to
zero, something could still go wrong,
despite having the best planning and
best management for cyber security.
So if there is a risk,
how do we sort of get a sense of how
much risk is that we still have?
What kind of risk are we dealing with?
Assessing such risk is important
because we talked about cost benefit.
So if you're going to make
investment in cyber security,
those investment decisions have to
be based on risk and its reduction.
So you're going to pay for
a certain control.
How much is the risk being reduced?
And they say risk is going to be reduced
because it's never going to be zero.
The only way to make it zero is you
disconnect from the rest of the world.
But then you can't do anything useful.
So some risk is going to remain,
and if the risk remains, well,
how do you quantify it if your
investments are going to be based?
Investments passed a certain control,
what are you going to pay for it?
Certainly, there's a number.
So if you're assessing risk or
quantifying it, how exactly do you?
It'll be great to say,
this is my risk and
this is what I can do to deal with it,
but how do you assess risk?
And one of the things we're
going to find out is that
quantifying it is actually not easy.
There are various frameworks
to sort of see what you do or
don't do that may pose
some degree of risk, but
actually quantifying it is what is hard,
so that's what we're talking about.